and now when you think back of undoing
all that stuff that you did do and and
think about those kind of races and
think about all the endurance and all
the different aspects of it did does it
ever seem kind of crazy that you did it
yeah like that I did I raced yeah I mean
now that you're not racing like whoa
what a wild way to make a living yeah
like I can't believe it happened to me
no [ __ ] like my dad was sort of this
invincible hero and I wanted to do what
he did I didn't think I was gonna get to
do that when I started doing it I was
thinking to myself I can't believe this
is happening to me when I started to win
I want a few rays I never man I never so
when I was in when I was 20 years old I
wasn't thinking man I'll be a champion
i'ma win 20 races I'm all the way in 50
races I'm gonna kick some ass I was
thinking I sure would love to do this
and pay my bills I would love to do this
just for a living not have to work
changing all it wasn't the best you know
wasn't where I wanted to be right
working in a service department was fun
but damn I wanted to be a race car
driver and so when I made it I didn't
really I wanted to win but damn I just
wanted to be able to make money to
afford to do it for a living and that's
all I ever wanted
so the wins Daytona 500 and all that
[ __ ] was a bonus and when I look back on
it now I'm like man I got was so lucky
holy cow was i lucky to do what we did
and do what I did and win what I did and
very lucky do you think you had such
great success not just because obviously
you're your dad is one of the greatest
of all time but also because your love
for it was what propelled you it wasn't
trying to seek fame or fortune it just
you just truly loved racing
and that's why you became so great at it
yeah my dad's the link to my father
opened up a [ __ ] ton of doors for me
open
so many opportunities for me all even
today it made my path much easier than
some other fellows that I know but I
think that my my passion for it and my
yeah my love for it my love for its
history my wanting for it to be healthy
the sport all those things is what
probably made me make good decisions as
I went along you know and when I would
talk or get in a position to make the
comment or say something I always tried
to think about how that would represent
the sport
I didn't understand what building a
brand meant till way too late in my
career
good yeah I mean good concentrating on
that it's always a mess yeah I don't
know I mean I wish I'd have known a
little bit about trying to build my
brand now it wouldn't been such a
hard-ass and hard to work with a lot of
times like there's been there were some
sponsors I loved and I did everything
they wanted and there were some that I
just weren't is I wasn't as good as I
should have been you know I wasn't you
know I have regrets but I'm just saying
like I did well as I was going through
this career I wasn't thinking about me
me me right I didn't even know how to
build my own brand I didn't know what
that meant I was thinking about man I
love this this is great I can't believe
I get to do this I can't believe I'm
here I can't believe I'm racing here
racing this person doing driving this
car got this sponsorship you know this
everything everything was the best of
the best you know I had had great
sponsors awesome awesome equipment
everybody always nice you know hey hey
you know it everybody's so nice
my wife just hates that cuz I'm
everywhere I go I'm like everybody's so
nice how was this but they were so nice
she goes everybody's nice to you you
know she she college she says she's I
don't know she just says you you know
that's normal people we don't get
everybody nice yeah different world yeah
that is interesting yeah you live in
this world where everybody's happy to
meet you yes like a hot chick
yeah all right me being like like a hot
[Laughter]
chicks do what the world's like
everywhere they go everybody loves them
yeah yeah
people super super excited to see them
yeah they know there's danger out there
and some of these men but sure
everybody's very friendly to that right
yeah very similar but